welcome back to psbg on sensor live from
New York City where British Iraqi rapper
and Pope Palestine activist Kareem
Dennis better known as lowkey has been a
powerful and influential Pro Palestinian
voice before and during this conflict
the official version of his track
terrorist was taken off YouTube after
the Hamas attacks in October the 7th 14
years after its initial release he's
been highly critical what he says is
media bias and accuse me of taking a
pro-israel slant on this show while I'm
joined Now by Loki who's at our London
Studio Loki thank you very very much
indeed for joining me I appreciate it
thank you for having me
piss um I I mean on the issue of whether
I'm pro-israel I I don't have a horse in
this race or this War I try and be
balanced I try and have all kinds of
views I think we've had more Pro
Palestinian people on this show in the
last two weeks than any other new show
in the world they've be getting huge
audiences so I would take issue with
that charge that somehow I'm slanted one
way or another I think this whole thing
is a complete tragedy I know that you've
been committed to the plight of the
Palestinians for a long time going back
at least 15 years from what I can see in
terms of you traveling to Gaza um what
was your reaction when you first heard
about these attacks on October the 7th
well let's be clear reading the
testimony of survivors of October 7th
from kibuts B like yes mean Pat was
extremely harrowing what she alleges is
not only that her husband was killed in
the initial takeover but also she then
says that the Israeli military tanks
fired on the room where the hostages
were killing 12 Israeli civilian
captives we have also seen fantastic
work in the haret newspaper by Amos
harell where he speaks at length about
uh Brigadier General Rosenfeld who was
in charge of the arett crossing now when
when this military base was taken over
what he says OS Harel in haret the
well-known Israeli newspaper he says
that Rosenfeld when he realized that the
base was overtaken called in an air
strike this is in haret these are not my
words these are the words of Amos Haro
what we then saw is since October the
7th 22 Israeli civilian detainees killed
in Gaza by Israeli airri strikes the
Israeli military has something called
the Hannibal directive the Hannibal
directive was developed in Lebanon in
the 80s by the Israelis with the clear
understanding that they do not want the
other side to take hostages so for
example you have the case of um had
Golding Golding in
2014 what Israel called operation
protective Edge which killed over 2,200
Palestinians but when
uh this Israeli soldier was taken
captive by the Palestinians Israel then
proceeded to kill everyone including the
civilians in the area around where he
was kept and the soldier himself so what
Israel has unfortunately is a policy of
killing captives if you look at the case
of gilad Shalit this was an Israel
listen allow me to finish allow me to
finish you can't just keep talking you
can't keep talking to make and I hope
that you'll allow me to make it in the
case of gadal what happened was one
Israeli soldier led to a thousand
Palestinian prisoners being released
there is a clear understanding within
the Israeli military and political Elite
that they do not want people to be
kidnapped so therefore they
unfortunately as history has shown us
and as the directive within the Israeli
military shows they take action to kill
their own captives that have been taken
by the other side right let me let me
respond to you you tweeted on October
the 7th the arrogance to believe you
could keep 2 million trapped in an open
air prison indefinitely dot dot dot that
appears to have been your only comment
about what happened so just for the
record do you condemn what Hamas did
that day I condemn the genocidal
conditions which have created this
violence every heartbeat every human
heartbeat is to me and that is what has
compelled me to work as I have for the
last 15 years to save lives to save
lives and stop people
dying no we do not have a clear picture
of what happened on October 7th because
unfortunately too much of the media has
relied on the Israeli military talking
points which are given directly to them
until observers until neutral observers
are able to establish the facts of
October 7th I will not I will not allow
the talking points of the Israeli
military to become dominant of what
happened on that day Palestinians are
subject to a genocidal War collect
punishment in Gaza is real resp let me
respond you are the only Pro Palestinian
person I've had on the show in two weeks
who has tried to make out that this just
didn't happen on October the 7th or
somehow misrepresenting what I am saying
do you do you well I've got two question
they're very straightforward do you
believe that 1500 people were
slaughtered including 260 people at a
music festival you're a musician and
secondly do you condemn the people who
did it they're not I would like to quote
something that you just said to the
former spokesperson for the IDF this was
your exact sentence not long ago you
said it's difficult to tell between
combatants and non- combatants so you
the implication of what you said was
somehow it was understandable that
Israel has killed a Palestinian child
every 15 minutes in for the last somehow
they couldn't tell that those children
were not combatants according to you no
I didn't say understandable I didn't say
that and I have said it is absolutely
appalling the number of children who are
dying in Gaza it's appalling and it will
get worse I make no bones about that at
all and I have to say and I have to say
but you have to start you have start
surely from a Humanity point of view I
can absolutely express my horror at the
deaths of Palestinian innocent civilians
as I have done many times over the years
I think it's horrifying and I think this
is why I I have a serious problem with
the proposed ground Invasion because I
think it will create unbelievably large
numbers of Civilian casualties and I'm
not sure that the strategy will work um
but I'm just curious why you who is I
know you care about people I know you
care passionately about the Palestinian
civilians but you're the only Pro
Palestine voice I've had who's even
tried to suggest that what Hamas did on
October the 7th was not as bad as we
think so is that what you think do we
think but what do we think P the
information is not clear as I've said to
you all human
life even tried to hide it I'm not
trying to hide anything you're trying to
hide
something respect with respect you are
trying to you are definitely trying to
dissemble here and I'll explain why I've
giving you an opportunity to Simply say
whether you condemn what Hamas did which
by the way they have brazenly boasted
about they posted videos celebrating
what they did there is no doubt about
what Hamas did they want you to know
what they did they want me to know that
they want the world to know they killed
Jewish people in the Maine and in Israel
with impunity 260 people in a music
festival babies grandmothers they
kidnapped 200 people God knows what's
happened to them them now you can shake
your head but what you can't do is deny
that that happened because Hamas have
admitted it brazenly and
with st and secondly if they if they've
admitted it do you condemn what they did
I absolutely mourn the loss of all human
life in this conflict and I have
struggled for 15 years of my life in a
way that appears to be honest you
haven't okay and I take you as an empath
athetic person with a high level of
emotional intelligence okay I have
struggled for 15 years of my life to
Stop The Killing for a ceasefire now to
stop deaths but I have to say peers that
actually this line of questioning
unfortunately on a personal level is
somewhat hypocritical and I'll explain
why on April 18th
20122 you said the exact phrase that you
feel like Nelson Mandela walking out of
prison on the long road to freedom of
speech today there is a statue for
Nelson Mandela outside Parliament now
Human Rights Watch Amnesty International
bate Salim and even the Harvard Law
School have said that Israel practices
apartheid against the Palestinian people
do you know what thec struggle against
apartheid entailed are you aware that
the ANC are believed to have very
unfortunately horrifically and terribly
taken the live lives of children and
civilians in their struggle against
apartheid so peers you seem absolutely
content to not only compare yourself to
Nelson Mandela who served 27 years in
jail for what they described as
terrorism at the time but yet you cannot
see what the vast majority of human
rights organizations in the world see
when they look at the Palestinians when
you look at UN resolution
194 paragraph 11 the Palestinians have
the right to return home almost a
million of them were displaced in 1948
with the foundation of the state of
Israel and what we are now on the brink
of is Palestinians million of millions
of them being driven into the cyanide
desert with help of the US Delta
Force
British a manufactured in Israeli
manufactured humanitarian catastrophe
inaz there is a 23% infant mortality
rate
inaz let me say something I completely
agree with you about the pl of the
Palestinian people I've tweeted about
this for the last two weeks no no to be
fair you haven't PE and this is not
journalism Shen AB journalism y was
journalism M AA that's journalism
Palestinians are reaching out from the
cage that Israel has put them in and
they are trying to speak to the world
and they are being met they are being
met with cold indifference and I would
say to you peers I would say to you that
that gentleman that you've just had on
the show Mark reg Mark regev he belongs
in the hag David portray us you know
Piers you made your reputation as
opposing the invasion of Iraq well I
would ask you journalist to journalist
how could you justify the interview you
just gave to the head of US forces in
that illegal occupation of Iraq that
David Petraeus LED he was then the head
of the CIA both of the individuals that
you have just had on this show deserve
to be in the ha tried for war crimes I
am not anything like them I have not
hurt a fly those two men have why are
they given the respectability that you
gave them with your interview and why am
I interrogated as if I am somehow
someone that could hurt a human being
well certainly in Mark Red's case I
pushed him hard on all the positions is
that adopting that wasn't hard let me
explain because I I did a tweet today
and I I meant every word of this I said
I have great respect for anybody who in
the immediate aftermath of this
appalling terror attack said it was
outrageous and appalling there are 1,500
Palestinians still under the rub in Gaza
exactly you've had your say they're
still under the rub they're still under
the rubble you're not bringing them up I
said those I said those who whose
instinctive reaction was not to feel
that and I think you're one of them
because your reaction was to say the
arrogance to think you could keep two
million people trapped in an open air
prison indefinitely as if somehow that
justified what happened that day didn't
justify you exactly what you're doing
you should be able the point the point
when that tweet was sent the point when
that wasent you had not seen anything
had happen you have had your you've had
your criticism of me and that's fine
you're perfectly entitled to it like I
said to you I all you said about me I
believe in free speech you're entitled
to your opinion of me of David Petraeus
of Mark regar but I'm also entitled to
judge you as somebody who did not find
it in themselves to express anything
involving any out expressed I've just
expressed it and and and P this is not
journalism the idea of us comparing our
moral compasses and somehow I have a
deficient moral compass somehow I am a
moral monster you know you know what's
true what's true is I am not the people
that have shown a cold indifference to
the ethnically cleansed Palestinians
dispossessed one in three every Refugee
in the world is Palestinian they are the
largest Refugee population those who
have turned a blind eye to their
suffering are those that need to be
seriously interrogated about their moral
compass and I would ask you I would ask
you before we end the show no I would
ask you that I am able to read out the
names of the 20 Palestinian journalists
that have been killed
because I have two more
guests 20 journalists so I'm beinged now
and I'll tell you something else you're
not being this badge this badge zoom in
on this badge this badge was given to me
by an employee of this building who said
they were told they could not wear this
badge because it was the Palestinian
flag you talk about uncensored this is
censored this badge anybody from an
employee in this building I have
told wear a BGE so that's a ridiculous
thing to say I'm in New York uh but good
to see you low key I appreciate you
coming on the
program